deutsche kulturlandschaften von bauern
geprägt getreidefelder reif für die
ernte kühe auf saftigen wiesen
doch was so selbstverständlich scheint
verändert sich ganz enorm immer mehr
bauern geben auf weil sie von ihren
höfen nicht mehr leben können
woran liegt das liegt das an der
globalisierung oder an der eu
agrarpolitik
oder ist die deutsche landwirtschaft
schlichtweg schlecht aufgestellt aber
vor allem wie kann man gegen diese
entwicklung gegensteuern
unser thema jetzt bei phoenix die
zukunft der landwirtschaft
es ist ein heißer tag im juli für den
abend sind schwere gewitter angekündigt
wir sind in grafschaft im vorgebirge in
der nähe von bonn
franz josef schäfer erntet den
winterweizen der ingenieur der
agrarwissenschaften ist bauer mit leib
und seele
wir sind derzeit bei der
winterweizenernte wir haben gestern
angefangen heute setzen wir fort
winterweizen brotgetreide also dran sind
sehr bemüht sich möglichst schnell vom
heim zu kriegen da das wetter umschlagen
kann und dann qualitäten nachlassen
das ist der schönste beruf den ich mir
vorstellen kann man sieht wie die
früchte wachsen man sieht wie weit man
sieht was man sieht abend was man
geschafft hat das mit dem tageswerk ist
komplizierter geworden das getreide ist
zwei wochen früher als normal reis wegen
der trockenheit die wetterlage ändern
sich häufiger so zieht sich die ernte in
die länge
der anbau von weizen ist für franz josef
schäfer fast schon nebensache
hauptsächlich pflanzt er erdbeeren an
weil das getreide nicht genug abwirft
und 7 tonnen weizen pro hektar wird er
ernten in diesem jahr das ist für die
region mit ihren guten boden ein
unterdurchschnittlicher wert der ganze
april war zu trocken so konnte sich der
weizen nicht richtig ausbilden
er kam ja in den letzten jahren fast
schon krisenhaft kann man sagen viele
bauern aufgeben müssen
4000 c 130 im jahr 2016 und offenbar
geht diese entwicklung so weiter wie
kommt das haben sie eine erklärung dafür
und ist es hier in ihrer umgebung auch
so da sind unsere umgebung auch so also
sind jetzt
betriebe die nicht die entsprechende
größe haben am um bei den aktuellen
preisen existieren zu können die nicht
über die entsprechende flächen
ausstattung verfügen und vor allem die
betriebe die kleine nachfolger haben
es ist ja zurzeit nicht so sehr lukrativ
landwirt zu werden sachen ja nur die
allgemeine diskussion mittlerweile sind
wir ja für alles umwelt fast alles
unglück in der welt verantwortlich und
das nimmt natürlich auch so ein bisschen
die motivation diesen beruf zu ergreifen
bauer schäfer ist genervt von der wie er
findet unsachlichen kritik an den bauern
besonders wenn die städter die keine
ahnung hätten von monokultur sprechen
und die schwankungen in der öffentlichen
diskussion die tun noch ihr übriges
aktuell ist der milchpreis wieder in
einer region wo er akzeptabel ist wo ein
auskommen erreichbar ist von einem guten
jahr die bild -zeitung betitelt die
bauern gehen kaputt bei den milchpreis
aktuell betiteln sie die der mutter
breit ist so hoch wie seit dem krieg
nicht mehr
also was will ich jetzt das gesamte doch
ein auskömmliches einkommen haben oder
den ich nur billige preise haben das ist
natürlich im konflikt und bald nicht und
bei aller bei aller diskussion um um
auskömmliche preise aber letztendlich
geht es darum die nahrungsmittel so
günstig wie möglich zu produzieren nicht
und das ist natürlich das worunter wie
auch letztendlich leiden wenn ich
zurückdenke als ich den betrieb vor 35
jahren übernommen habe da hat getreide
und milch doppelt so viel gekostet wie
heute so werden sie natürlich diese
diese 35 jahre zurückverfolgen inflation
kostensteigerung dann wissen sie dass
dann kann ein kleiner betrieb nicht
überleben da musste also wachsen
und je mehr betriebe aufgeben größer
werden die einheiten je mehr große
maschinen sind auf dem feld je mehr
industrielle landwirtschaft werden wir
haben
die landwirtschaft hat sich im laufe der
zeit stark verändert
zu beginn des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
waren 38 prozent der menschen in der
landwirtschaft beschäftigt heute sind es
nur noch knapp 15 prozent um 1900 konnte
ein bauer vier menschen ernähren heute
sind es rund 150
die wichtigste feld ruft die hierzulande
angebaut wird ist nach wie vor der
weizen ausgangsprodukt für brot und
brötchen mit der eu-agrarpolitik kennt
er sich aus
bernhard conzen aus gangelt an der
holländischen grenze konnten bauteilen
zuckerrüben an
in diesem bereich steht im herbst eine
große zäsur an
dann endet das quotensystem wie einst
bei der milch die verwerfungen die damit
einhergehen könnten nicht er scheinbar
gelassen
wir nennen das strukturwandel der ganz
normal ist der sich über jahrzehnte in
einer größenordnung zwischen 1 5 und 2
prozent ergeben hat in den letzten
jahren hat der strukturwandel etwas an
fahrt aufgenommen hat derweil halt die
märkte und europäisches recht sich
verändern
die verbrauchsgewohnheiten der
verbraucher anders geworden sind und das
führt natürlich dazu dass sie auch in
der landwirtschaft vieles verändert bis
diese marktbereinigung nur für
deutschland zu beobachten oder
beispielsweise auch in den niederlanden
oder in frankreich dieses phänomen ist
überall wir sind ein europäischer markt
wir sind ja nicht mehr alleine unterwegs
sondern wir sind europa oder leben
europa und das heißt in allen bereichen
installation deutschland ist so ein
fruchtbares land überall gedeihen die
produkte trotzdem ist deutschland immer
mehr importland von lebensmitteln woran
liegt es das liegt einfach daran wir
leben ja mit unseren nachbarn ja
miteinander und jeder möchte ich auch
etwas verkaufen so das heißt also wir
sind verpflichtet als deutschland die
wir einen export auch haben importe ins
land hinein zu nehmen so das heißt die
vielfältigkeit der
druck nimmt natürlich zu die
standardprodukte die wir produzieren
gehen gern auch schon mal ins ausland
gefahren so gibt es eben produkte die
auch aus dem ausland die wir nicht so
herstellen geschmacksfrage ezb kommen
natürlich in den markt hinein der
austausch floriert da leben wir ja von
gewerkschaft nun gibt es eine neuauflage
der europäischen agrarpolitik ab 2020
wird die neu kreiert sozusagen die
diskussionen laufen gerade mit welchen
forderungen gehen sie denn da nach
brüssel
ja was in unserer forderung zunächst mal
ist sehr wichtig dass bei dem wallenden
märkten die wir jetzt haben und damit
sind natürlich die einkommen auch ganz
stark mal mehr mal weniger um in der
landwirtschaft dieses etwas zu glätten
brauchen wir verlässliche politik
einkommensstützung in der form es gibt
die erste und zweite säule einkommens
wirksam ist im grunde genommen die erste
säule nur die zweite säule ist für
greening und andere auflagen belegt
dafür muss man leistung und draußen
bringen und das ist wichtig dass die
erhalten bleiben für die zukunft damit
für die betriebe zu mindestens eine
basis da ist damit sie überleben können
wenn die märkte mal aus dem ruder laufen
klingt noch mehr sozialismus ist kein
sozialismus man muss sich einfach
überlegen was man will
willich kulturpflege haben möchte ich
eine landwirtschaft haben wie sie heute
ist in kleineren strukturen
dann muss ich dafür sehen dass ich da
einen ausgleich schaffen wenn ich große
strukturen schaffen will nehme ich das
weg dann haben wir das wie im osten mit
3 und 4000 hektar dann haben wir hier
nur noch flächen
ich sag mal 100 hektar oder 200 hektar
weizen am stück dann ist die frage der
biodiversität und alles das was wir ja
hier in unserem bereich versuchen zu
stützen alles perdu dieses thema ist bei
uns eigentlich schon seit längerem
bekannt die chancen sehen wir sehr
deutlich vor allen dingen ab fachkräfte
zu bekommen wird immer schwieriger die
flächen delegation in der landwirtschaft
nimmt zu und da brauchen wir eigentlich
die digitalisierung erfassung von
flächen autonomes fahren
auftragsbearbeitung
transparenz auch nach außen bei den
kontrollen und da hilft uns natürlich
die digitalisierung sehr weil wir dieses
nicht alles handschriftlich manuell
machen müssen sondern es wird direkt von
einer maschine oder wie auch immer
gleich aufgenommen und abgefasst und ist
damit erkennbar für ihn wenn sie sagen
möglicherweise wird es in der zukunft
für den einen oder anderen bauern darauf
ankommen sich zu entscheiden ob
vielleicht weniger mehr ist in zukunft
welche rolle kann dann die biologische
landwirtschaft spielen denn im letzten
jahr hatte ich auch zuwächse von 75
prozent gegeben bei den biohöfen fair
dass eine möglichkeit oder sagen sie als
vertreter der konventionellen
landwirtschaft das wird ein peanuts
bereich bleiben zunächst mal sich für
uns ein bereich wir vertreten beide
richtungen
wer in diesem segment unterwegs ist und
sein einkommen stabilisieren kann
weil die märkte ja da sind dann soll er
die bedien und dann ist das auch okay
und richtig so wenn der verbraucher sagt
sind ja nicht alle verbraucher die sehr
bewusst einkaufen oder gesund überdenken
in den dingen und sagen so das will ich
haben diesen weg konventionell nach wie
vor das wird das gros seien richtig
aufgestellt unsere bauern ob wie
konventionell oder biologisch
wirtschaften sind für uns vom ansatz die
gleichen weil wir produzieren
lebensmittel auf dem acker so wäre das
eine kann kann das andere
ob biologisch oder nicht später keine
rolle der verbraucher ist derjenige der
uns sagt was er will und dafür füllen
die sommer noch zum schluss nach vorne
herr ganzen zukunft der landwirtschaft
wie sieht ihr aus in deutschland in 10
15 jahren ist der bauer der vor seinem
haus ein misthaufen hat auf dem der hahn
kräht und die glücklichen hühner
rumlaufen ist ja sozusagen ein
romantisches bild der vergangenheit aus
den 70er und 80er jahren des letzten
jahrtausends
ja da bin ich bei ihnen das wird es
nicht mehr geben alleine schon aus der
rechtlichen grundlage heraus dass dieses
umwelttechnisch ganz mehr möglich ist
solche anlagen müssen heute
umwelttechnisch vernünftig angelegt sein
das heißt es wird noch ein misthaufen
geben auch sie wird nicht mehr irgendwo
vor der tür liegen oder in einer
auch schafft sondern wir dahin gelegt
oder da sein wo im grunde genommen die
anlagen stehen und wir können davon
ausgehen dass die entwicklung der
landwirtschaft ernährung wird es immer
geben und in ernährung müssen wir in 25
jahren 60 prozent auf heute mehr an
lebensmittel zur verfügung stellen damit
die menschheit überhaupt ernährt werden
kann
damit sehe ich eigentlich eine große
perspektive für uns landwirte oder man
braucht uns man soll uns respektieren
wir machen einen guten job die meisten
haben sechs sieben jahre ausbildung
bevor sie in die praxis reingehen
ich glaube ich kein berufszweig der so
nachhaltig und tief ausgebildet wird
heute um im grunde genommen den
erfordernissen an umwelt an klima etc pp
gerecht zu werden 60 prozent mehr an
lebensmitteln in den nächsten 25 jahren
sollen die bauern produzieren wird dass
der boden hergeben
wohl kaum ohne gentechnisch veränderte
pflanzen die artenvielfalt leidet sagt
die präsidentin des bundesamtes für
naturschutz vor professor hesse welche
arten sind denn aus ihrer sicht
besonders in mitleidenschaft gezogen wir
beobachten in der teils dramatische
bestands rückgänge einzelne arten
gruppen in der agrarlandschaft zu nennen
wären da zum beispiel die feldvögel die
agrar vögel verschiedene insekten
gruppen wie zum beispiel die wildbienen
die ja auch für die bestäubung wichtig
sind oder die sogenannten
ackerwildkräuter und es ist doch schon
bezeichnend dass viele arten die die
bezeichnung fällt im namen führen
mittlerweile stark rückläufig oder sogar
gefährdet sind etwa der feldhamster der
in vielen gegenden deutschlands schon
fast ausgestorben ist oder ganz
verschwunden ist die feldlerche oder
sogar der feldsperling wie hat sich das
in den letzten jahren entwickelt hat
sich das verändert hat hat das
zugenommen diese entwicklung hält schon
seit längerer zeit an eigentlich seitdem
wir die intensivierung die zunehmende
intensivierung in der landwirtschaft
beobachten
aber es ist eine entwicklung die eben
weiterhin ungebremst verläuft und sie
betrifft eben nicht nur einzelne tier
und pflanzenarten sondern auch die
lebensräume in der agrarlandschaft als
wirklich dramatisch muss man die
situation beim kuh
land bezeichnen hier verzeichnen wir
einen rückgang gerade artenreicher
grünland lebensräume zum beispiel
unserer blütenreichen wiesen und weiden
jetzt hören sie bauen sich zu unrecht
kritisiert und sagen der rückgang der
artenvielfalt könne ja sein aber die
verstädterung und die versiegelung des
bodens könnten durchaus auch ursachen
dafür seien was sagen sie dazu
es ist schon so der rückgang der
biologischen vielfalt hat viele ursachen
zu nennen sind der landnutzung wandels
zu nennen sind stoff einträge etwa durch
stickstoff und düngemittel und natürlich
auch die flächeninanspruchnahme und die
zunehmende zerschneidung der landschaft
spielen hier eine rolle ist geht dabei
aber nicht um wechselseitige
schuldzuweisungen sondern es geht darum
die ursachen zu benennen und für die
kulturlandschaft für die agrarlandschaft
muss man ganz klar sagen da gibt es
viele studien eine ganze reihe auch von
wissenschaftlichen untersuchungen die
belegen dass die landwirtschaft einer
der hauptverursacher des artenrückgangs
ist ja interessant fand ich die
beobachtung jetzt im sommer wenn man
sich felder anschaut war wo
beispielsweise weizen oder roggen weg
dass zwischen den einzelnen ehren
überhaupt keine anderen pflanzen mehr zu
sehen sind und ich meine dass es früher
anders war wie kommt denn das stimmt in
diese beobachtung
diese beobachtung stimmt insoweit als
dass man sich einmal vor augen führen
muss dass vielleicht noch vor zehn
zwanzig jahren unsere landschaften
unsere äcker auch ein anderes bild
geboten haben da hat die kornblume drin
geblüht der acker rittersporn der auch
sehr schön blau blüht das sommer
adonisröschen auch der klatschmohn das
sind die sogenannten ackerwildkräuter
und diese gruppe ist in der
agrarlandschaft in der tat sehr stark
rückläufig sowohl im inneren der äcker
darüber dauern häufig nur einige wenige
arten die an diese intensive
bewirtschaftung angepasst sind
man muss sich aber auch einmal
vergegenwärtigen die bewirtschaftung
einheiten die pflege wie man sagt in der
landschaft sind ja auch immer größer
geworden
dadurch gehen die rand strukturen zurück
ist verschwinden die früheren
blütenreichen räume und die sind für
viele blüten bestäuben die insekten
wichtig die nunmehr keine nahrung finden
sich von insekten ist ein weiteres thema
was viele leute wie ich weiß beschäftigt
viele ich sage es mal über 40 jährige
können sich noch daran erinnern dass
wenn man früher im sommer auto gefahren
ist dass die scheibe ganz auf voller
insekten war das hat abgenommen und wenn
man mit offenen augen wiederum durch die
landschaft geht dann beobachtet man ja
auch dass es viel weniger insekten zu
geben scheint schmetterlinge
beispielsweise stimmt diese beobachtung
und woran liegt es gut dieser
windschutzscheiben effekt das ist
natürlich etwas sehr plakatives mit dem
man das veranschaulichen kann
es gibt aber auch sehr viele
wissenschaftliche untersuchungen die in
der tat gelegen
wir haben es mit einem sehr starken
rückgang von insekten zu tun
die artenvielfalt ist sehr stark
zurückgegangen was auf aber noch stärker
zu denken gibt es nicht nur die
einzelnen arten von insekten neben ab
und verschwinden sondern die
bestandszahlen die wir sagen die
populationsgröße gehen sehr stark zurück
und eben insgesamt die menge der
insekten die biomasse und die ist in der
tat das belegen regionale studien in
einzelnen bereichen in einzelnen räumen
wo das konkret nachgewiesen wurde um 80
euro um bis zu 80 prozent rückläufig
vielen sagen und dann bis hierher frau
professorin jessel also offenbar gibt es
da was irgendwie irre und insekten
angeht durchaus probleme das ist den
meisten bauern nicht egal zum beispiel
in norddeutschland sie versuchen dagegen
vorzugehen indem sogenannte inseln für
tiere geschaffen werden
frau professor jessel ist ja so eine
maßnahme die sie unterstützen würden man
darf die motivation vieler landwirtinnen
und landwirte sich für den erhalt ihrer
umwelt und für den naturschutz zu
engagieren
in der tat nicht unterschätzen es gibt
ja viele beispiele wo freiwillig
lerchenfenster angelegt werden um
lerchen den fluten zu erleichtern um
strukturen zb für das rebhuhn geschaffen
werden nur solche freiwilligen
massnahmen reichen unter dem strich
nicht aus ich denke der fehler liegt im
system
in der derzeitigen ausgestaltung der
agrarpolitik die eben nicht hinreichend
anreize setzt damit landwirte die auf
breiter fläche naturverträglich
wirtschaften dafür eben auch
entsprechend und zielgerichtet entlohnt
werden
stichwort gemeinsame agrarpolitik der
europäischen union
da steht ja die nächste reform an in der
kritik bei ihnen ist besonders da das
sogenannte greening was ist das und was
fordern sie im hinblick darauf dass
screening wurde mit der aktuellen
förderperiode der agrarpolitik der
garten der europäischen agrarpolitik im
jahr 2014 eingeführt
es besteht aus mehreren komponenten
betriebe ab 15 hektar ackerfläche müssen
auf mindestens fünf prozent ihrer fläche
so genannte ökologische vorrangflächen
anlegen
nun dieser wert wird zwar auch auf dem
papier tatsächlich erreicht wenn man
aber genau hinschaut dann zeigt sich 80
prozent dieser vorrangflächen sind
bestanden mit leguminosen und
zwischenfrüchten das bringt für die
biologische vielfalt für die
biodiversität wenig bis nichts eine
weitere greening komponente ist der
grünland erhalt beim sogenannten umwelt
sensiblen grünland da hat man aber bei
uns in deutschland die
schutzbestimmungen nur sehr unzureichend
umgesetzt indem nur in ffh-gebieten
dieses grünland dafür ein absolutes
umbruchverbot herrscht und wir
beobachten ja gerade beim grünland unter
dem strich eine dramatische
verschlechterung in der qualität die
sich in einem rückgang der artenvielfalt
ausdrückt insgesamt muss man deswegen
leider sagen ist das screening eine
ineffektive und gleichzeitig wenn man
bedenke sind 1 5 milliarden euro die
dafür jährlich aufgewendet werden auch
eine zu teure maßen und welche
forderungen leute sich daraus nun wir
sollten da hinkommen dass landwirtinnen
und landwirte die naturverträglich
wirtschaften dafür auch entsprechend
honoriert werden sie erbringen ja
zugleich auch zahlreiche leistungen für
die gesellschaft durch den erhalt
intakter kulturlandschaften wie zum
beispiel für den tourismus wichtig sind
durch die nachhaltigen erhalt des bodens
zum beispiel was den humusgehalt
betrifft oder das grundwasser wenn man
an die nitrat einträge mitdenkt und
grundwasser wird ja zugleich auch als
trinkwasser genutzt
solche leistungen die sollten gezielt
honoriert werden der grundsatz sollte
geld mit öffentliches geld für
öffentliche leistungen
man muss sich ja einmal vor augen führen
aus dem gesamten eu haushalts sind es
knapp 40 prozent das sind in der
laufenden förderperiode 313 milliarden
euro
im wesentlichen aus steuergeldern kommen
und die an die landwirte gehen und
dieses geld sollte zielgerichtet
eingesetzt werden um ich betone es
nochmals landwirte die naturverträglich
wirtschaften dafür tatsächlich auch zu
honorieren so dass sich dieses diese
bewirtschaftung auch auskömmlich tätigen
können
mit der natur verbunden naturverträglich
wirtschaften das hat sich auch der
bräunerhof auf die fahne geschrieben
wir sind in lindlar für im bergischen
land alte höfe ist schon früh auf dem
feld er erntet wie geboren
die machen hier zu wählen
wenn ihr noch klappt sind die kerne
macht zu klein um zwischendurch auch
immer mal wieder eine aufmachung und wir
dafür zu kriegen
und siehe da die keiner so groß gemacht
es ist sein erster sommer als
gemüsebauer erste märz ist er mit frau
und tochter hierhin gezogen
zweieinhalb hektar land hat höfl auf dem
brühler hof gepachtet in sechs parzellen
geteilt unterschiedlich bepflanzt neben
dem gemüse wächst wald stauden roggen
der soll den boden gründlich durch
wurzeln und regenerieren
das ist auch der grund warum die anbau
sorten regelmäßig gewechselt werden
reiterhöfe ist dem demeter verband
angeschlossen das land wird nach
strengen biologischen grundsätzen
bestellt es wird großen wert auf
kreislaufwirtschaft gelegt auf eigene
sorten und züchtungsarbeit gentechnik
dies streng verboten
höfl hat die bestellungen von ein paar
bioläden aus dem bergischen land
aufgeladen und dampf ab richtung hof zum
frühstück auf dem bauernhof lebt eine
bunte truppe von allah freaks und
freigeister inklusive flüchtling aus
ghana wie gefährlich die und den namen
ist dem er arbeitet nicht nur biologisch
salam biodynamisch und das ist wirklich
ein lebenskonzept wer sich einfach in
die gesamte landwirtschaft in alle
bereiche ziehen
insofern ist das nicht mit einem satz
also nicht einfach nur wir haben keine
pflanzenschutzmittel es eher so eine
gewinnung einfach wie gehen wir mit den
tieren mit der umwelt mit dem boden um
es einfach ein gesamtkonzept albrecht
noch mehr power in der achten generation
ist nicht nur der chef sondern auch so
etwas wie der philosophische mittelpunkt
des preuner hofes sein umgang mit den
tieren hat sich mit den jahren verändert
wird rennen quasi von ihren kälbern weil
das wirtschaftlich gerechnet weil wir im
wettbewerb stehen und dann blendet man
viele sachen aus und will sich da gar
nicht mehr mit konfrontieren wenn halt
für trauern wenn sie ihr kalb abgegeben
haben und dann ist mir jetzt noch mal so
ganz bewusst geworden hier weil er ist
so normal geworden
und weil er das leid der tiere nicht
mehr ausblenden will bleiben auf dem
bräunerhof muttertiere und kälber
zusammen bis sie eigene wege gehen
die 75 kühe bringen keine reichtümer
aber bürger hatten auskommen
zufriedenheit ist immer wichtiger
dieser seat dieses berufes der ist halt
so lange in vergessenheit geraten obwohl
man jeden tag davon den körper gestaltet
die thor vollen teller leer und diese
zusammenhänge einfach die
wiederzuerkennen einfach also dass wir
mir ein anliegen dass wir also wieder
bewusster uns mit den geschenken
ausländer zu beschäftigen
bewusster mit den lebewesen und den
geschenken der natur umgehen liegt darin
vielleicht auch ein wenig die zukunft
der landwirtschaft und damit endet dann
unser phoenix thema zukunft der
landwirtschaft vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit und bis dahin